what's up everyone this is Anthony
papiano most of you know me as pump
you're listening to off the chain
simply the best podcasting crypto let's
kick this thing off
[Music]
the following episode is part of the
off-the-chain automation series
sponsored by iota the goal of this
special series is to explore the
intersection of distributed ledger
technology and automation specifically
around digital currencies digital
wallets and machine-to-machine
transactions my core belief is that
every stock bond currency and commodity
will eventually be digitized and
distributed ledger technology will
empower the full potential of automation
to be realized
iota is the sponsor of the automation
series their mission is to support the
research and development of new
distributed ledger technologies
including IOT tangle the iota foundation
encourages the education and adoption of
distributed ledger technologies through
the creation of ecosystems and the
standardization of these new protocols
you can find out more about the
automation series and iota in the show
notes
Anthony pomp Liana is a partner at
Morgan Creek digital all opinions
expressed by palm or his guests on this
podcast are solely their opinions and do
not reflect the opinions of more Creek
digital or Morgan Creek Capital
Management you should not treat any
opinion expressed by pomp as a specific
inducement to make a particular
investment or follow a particular
strategy but only as an expression of
his opinion this podcast is for
informational purposes only
alright guys bang bang I've got Jason
here with me super excited to have this
conversation so thanks for so much
taking the time to do this sir over here
my pleasure
let's so let's jump right into your
background obviously you know you used
to know a lot of time at Dell but kind
of you know what would you do before get
into Dell so I actually was I'm a
mechanical engineer out of school I went
to UT here in Austin got into I actually
started at Dell of doing design of like
the computer cases plastic and sheet
metal tab design and then I know I've
always been though interested in yeah
I'd like to say if it's fuzzy I'm on it
you know any kind of forward-looking
stuff and I just started kind of driving
my teams to do more R&D so that kind of
led me into R&D roles eventually into
seats
yo rolls there was a stent where I was
at in the startup world for a while and
that kind of got me to experience
wearing a lot of different hats and then
when I came back to doe in 2006
just-just-just always in your kind of
was able to get into the the
forward-looking innovation roles which
you also have ultimately like said there
would be more in the software side and
then you know the business focus around
it and that kind of led me to hey what
do we want to do with IOT in 2014 as the
the buzz really started picking up and
and as I always tell my team the best
way to get a job is to already be doing
it so we just started employing building
a strategy within a small core team and
that kind of led me to you know in my
current role as CTO for IOT magic at
Dell technologies so it's been a it's
been a good ride but it's always about
kind of finding finding gaps you've
surrounded yourself with really good
people and being inquisitive and just go
make stuff happen for sure and it's a
great outlook on life in general talk
about the package you've got a ton of
patents that you guys have have written
in and are in your name maybe talk a
little bit about what some of those are
and how they came about well yeah and
they actually kind of tracked the
progression you know a lot of the
earlier ones that I've done with you
know over the years have been kind of
more of mechanical type things and then
they start looking more like the more
more software over time there was a
stent where we were working with this
team focused on how do we improve remote
collaboration tools so that a number of
patents around that we're doing things
around session continuity back I guess
it was over ten years ago around how you
can drop off from one device and pick up
on another and of course that's a that's
a big different ecosystem spay we all
most recently we've been getting into a
lot of stuff around on of course IOT
probably speaking an edge but then also
lots of work around how do you would
impart like intrinsic trust across
networks because if we can't get to this
notion of trust at scale it's going to
be very difficult to realize the true
potential of your time so just it's a
whole slew of stuff but
yeah you know lots of lots of fun
different areas of um working it for
sure what's like the weirdest thing that
you've worked on in technology side oh
that's such a that's a what's the
weirdest thing there's so many different
things
what's your fate your favorite kind of
patent that uh that you guys put
together and we did we did one that was
around you know you're walking down the
hall and you see somebody and they're
like oh man I've been meaning to ask you
for like three weeks like like that's
one thing you work at home like remotely
and you don't talk to anybody you've got
all these people sitting statically in
your I am window and you might just get
consumed with your work and and then you
go back to work and immediately starts
oh hey I'm if you sit whatever so we did
one atom worry literally as people would
walk about people would kind of like
dynamically walk by a based on an
algorithm your screen so it's kind of
like walking by somebody in your hallway
and so it would be randomized and kind
of automated in them the patent also
included some stuff around you based on
the schedules that you meet mutually
have it would force a virtual
interaction with someone depending on
you know kind of that the fact that you
would have been walking by the actual
physical Hall because you were in those
kinds of rooms those kinds of different
claims around that kind of stuff but
this notion of combining physical and
virtual and making you feel more like
you're sort of in that in that physical
world while you're working with motely
so get a bunch of things kind of like
that that's pretty cool I like that one
yeah another one was around white white
boarding any white board on the screen
and say you watch a video of some people
that white boarding and it's like the
squiggly massive stuff in the end and
you know you go back as it maybe you
missed the meeting and you're like
looking at this the people's camera
pictures of the smartphone pictures over
the whiteboard and you're like I have no
clue what that drawing is because it was
all done you know in real time and
people have different conversations and
so the patent was around if you clicked
one line within that whiteboard and it
would play you the recording of
conversation when that line was drawn so
you can kind of get the immediate
context yeah a lot of kinds of stuff
like that got it and in soon today you
are what the CTO of IOT and edge
computing at Dell
yeah a delta phonologies yeah so so for
the portfolio but if you're looking at
the look at the IOT and edge computing
is a broader term big big trend you know
and I'm not the way I like to do things
with with with the teams is let's focus
on outcomes and then let's back into
technologies so so IOT with more devices
coming online you know that scale
represents a big new workload a big new
opportunity but ultimately it's really
about focus on the outcome focus on the
use case and then back into it all these
technologies and them then you get into
things like AI and a RvR and the 5g and
all these different new technologies
it's best to start with the out comfort
and then you're back into it so yeah
initially of course at the core focus on
IOT maybe just walk us through for those
that don't know you know what IOT is and
then what edge computing is right your
i'll venture to say you're an expert in
this so kind of how do you describe both
of those trends or themes to uh to folks
yeah yeah definitely so so IOT I mean
it's it's it's not one single thing we
joke all the time people they're like
hey I'd like to buy some IOT sigh but
really what color would you like you
know I mean it's it's your eye o T as a
collection of things but really it's
about this notion of more devices not
associated with a particular user so
autonomous in that sense you know placed
out in the physical world collecting
data about the physical world in in you
know feeding that into compute systems
and in the purest sense you just give me
visibility from the physical world you
know sensors are on temperature pressure
vibration cameras or one of the best
sensors around so computer vision is
definitely kind of a close parallel to
IOT
with with image based data but you bring
all this data into systems maybe giving
me some visibility but then when you
start applying analytic
ái on top of that and driving change
that's when it gets super value and you
start kind of automating things and
whether it's in cities or or building
automation obviously you have a lot of
smart homes stuff so the things with
your lights and you know your Lexus and
all that kind of stuff that would be
considered IOT in general so just more
devices online driving more data that
drive more analytics that help make
things better is kind of IOT but with
more of these things coming online we
just have so much data coming from the
edge edge the device X
laptops tablets you know all kinds of
different sensors traversing networks
all that data and there's a point where
there's so much data that it just it
grates bandwidth issues who creates
latency issues for response if I if I
need an immediate response and I cannot
tolerate any kind of downtime like if
I'm a a factory and I have a robot on
the floor I need immediate response or
there's a safety issue in many cases I
don't care how many nines your
reliability has on the tail end for your
network a wide area network like a cell
network you will not deploy your airbag
from the from the cloud not gonna happen
and so so there's there's a need for
edge computing so this this is about
moving more compute closer to the edge
for reasons of latency I need immediate
response bandwidth I've just got so much
data that I'm getting from these devices
that I can't send them over these
networks because it just cost too much
money security if I'm a nuclear plant
I'm not going to be hooking up to the
cloud you know that just exposes too
much risk and then and then the but the
kicker ultimately is is around around
the cost of just moving a bunch of data
around the way I define edge computing
is moving compute as close as both
necessary and feasible to the
subscribers that need it so you know
like in the sense of like the Netflix
they're moving more and more of the
content close to the cloud edge you know
where the
KO's can then bridge that to your homes
I often explain why we need that's
computing with cat videos my wife and I
have three cats and and in that videos
is why we need the internet first off of
course and then also we need more
educating because videos go viral I have
to cache it closer to the subscribers if
I'm a operations person I need to run
compute close to my factory floor in my
industrial you'll plant chemical plant
whatever from a chemical or nuclear
plant I won't you'll connect to the
cloud in many cases or I'll use a beta
diode so data can only go one way I
can't have any sort of attacks to me in
a much in the airbag example but it's
really about this continuum across the
board really important to understand is
that in the IT world you know there's a
lot of standardization you know over the
years of course the cloud is not going
away there's a bunch of click bait out
there as they know the clouds going away
the edge is gonna eat the cloud or
whatever not the case you can still see
an incredible amount of stuff than the
cloud but you're just gonna see more and
more done at the edge an IT stuff is
fairly standardized a lot of good stuff
happening you in that front but the the
OT world operations world close to the
physical world where where processes
happen
it is really fragmented it's really
messy there's a lot of where people live
and people are complicated and and so
dealing with that inherent inherently
heterogeneous nature of the edge is
challenging in the IT world if with what
they're this worth in the OT world if
there is a security issue or a breach
there was immediate loss of production
or a risk to life if not loss of life in
the OT world in the IT world it tends to
be if there's a breach it tends to be a
super long tail like a credit card
breach where it for years you play out
you play out you know that the losses
format so I like to say you know a you
know IOT start some OTN scales and I T
we don't know where computes gonna be
running in the end from the edge of the
cloud so you really need to architect
that switch you kind of need to talk to
you from that but it's
a lot of interesting trends and
challenges when you deal with IOT
imagine and how it all comes together
but ultimately it is about let's focus
on outcomes and then back into it the
right thing the right thing for sure
yeah and look I think in encrypt dos
specifically but obviously in things
like IOT and edge as well we see it all
time right people get enamored with the
technology they then go looking for a
problem to solve with this new piece of
technology rather than working kind of
in Reverse where let's start mopping the
problem and then figure out what
technologies empower us to do that ya
know just because you can doesn't mean
you should for sure okay
so let's get a little bit more into
automation right I look at automation as
kind of one of these catch-all phrases
because there's no magic wand of
automation right Automation essentially
comes down to things like computing
power algorithms software you know a lot
of kind of logic and controllers etc but
how do you kind of sitting in your seat
at Dell technologies think about
automation or is there anything
specifically that you guys are working
on in that space and then you know after
we touch on that maybe we can get into
some of the technologies you guys are
using
yeah Automation yeah it means it means a
lot of different stuff to different
people and of course your automation and
you know in the purest sense has been
done in like the OT world operations
technology world for a long time when
you think of like process control
there's been you know programmable logic
controllers PLC's and factory floors for
quite a while SCADA systems etc they've
been doing these types of things for a
while and manufacturing of course you've
got automation within to a certain
degree within lots of systems even cars
and all that but it's the the level of
it is changing and then there's also
this notion of automation and the purest
sense on a factory floor has been
running for a long time maybe building
some widget but you don't necessarily
know what's happening in the moment
there's many cases in the history of
manufacturing where you could be running
your process for days if not weeks and
not know that you're making bad parts
and so a lot of the what's new is that
when were working you know dealt
apologies with a lot of companies you
provide infrastructure we work with with
them in different domain experts on top
and
the different fields is how do I provide
quote/unquote real-time visibility to
this process and it starts with
visibility but then over time you're
going to start seeing more you know
taking taking automated action on
automatic action on the insights that
you gained but this is where when you
look at automation where it's also very
important I think going back to what I
was saying about kind of the ITM OT
worlds and then the degree of risk when
you do something in the OT world
immediate loss of production life in the
IT world it's a hey sorry you couldn't
get your email and shut down the network
as I was concerned breach
you know you can't just shut down a
factory floor I joke all the time you
can't just willy-nilly update you know
things on a factory floor you know
imagine a screen that said hey save your
work your production line is rebooting
in 15 minutes we're doing an update you
know you just can't do that and so when
you think about automation you also have
to think about the the processes
involved the stakeholders involved the
risk of if you make a decision that's
that's um that creates an issue walking
into the room termit turning on the
lights kind of automation is not a big
deal you know it will risk making that
decision in an autonomous fashion making
a big decision around turning off your
you know your production line because of
some some issue or making some change to
the process is different and so what
you'll see in the in the industrial
sense typically today is even if
someone's collecting data bringing it
into some sort of analytics scenario may
be applying some AI machine learning
whatever to do you know process
improvement very it would be very
untypical at this point for that that
decision hey we could tweak this
parameter and make them at the factory
more efficient very untypical today with
that decision be automated back into the
factory floor because of the
implications what will happen is that
decision will be fed to a an expert on
the floor or or used in the production
facility and then that person would
I do I make that change and so it's me
we look out a mation and I think this is
really important to think about the
implications of doing so and and that
there's also this need for trust and how
it's done
across these networks and so it's it's
really in this is why it's so
interesting and so important to talk
about this kind of the notion of people
and technology all together last thing
I'll say on that is real time is a very
loaded word there's a lot of loaded
terms in technology real-time to a
building automation person in terms of
making some sort of gathering data and
from from the building around
temperature and whatever is like 15
minutes I I would consider that
real-time as a building person if I'm a
manufacturing person or from an airbag
you know as an easy example I think real
time is a fraction of a second that is
deterministic the message must get there
in time or there's a problem if I'm a
financial institution I think real time
is a fraction of a second but but no
one's gonna die if your Starbucks
doesn't get me think doesn't go through
and transaction so it's we've got to be
really consider when we do automation
all these different things so and I mean
we can talk about some examples and but
but it's just it's really a shame thing
and not too many people just said oh
we're going to go automate everything
without thinking of the implications
we're sure and and it's so interesting
to hear you say you know the need for
automation but but the kind of real-time
nature being loaded works right
it's it really is so true and obviously
kind of elephant in the room I guess is
as you talk about automation and this
need for trust how do you think about
that being solved you know one of the
technologies obviously that a lot of the
listeners on this podcast pay attention
to blockchain crypto Bitcoin etc and the
blockchain technology solving for that
trust by allowing people to verify
information is that something that you
guys are looking at is you try to solve
the truss problem in automation or using
other technologies I just talked a
little bit about that yeah so so it's a
system-level trust is key you know how
do you mitigate between across all of
these different and
only inherently different stakeholders
heterogeneous systems so-so ledger
technologies blockchain you know I think
are part of it you obviously some of my
blogs about blockchain being kind of a
Windex of technology if you ever seen
that the movie My Big Fat Greek Wedding
and the bad sprays Windex on everything
you know you've got a paper cut out get
some Winnick and and and says you know
blockchain aia r vr v g all these
different things I call them all wind
exes of technology people overuse the
terms and in and you would have seen
over the past number of years only two
years ago you could have just said
blockchain and someone would throw a
million dollars at you you know PC money
and now it's kind of dried out because
there's challenges with with the compute
power require there's some
inefficiencies if you're in a cold
supply chain scenario and someone gets
sick and dies because you were the
reason why you know that their food went
out of temperature and got contaminated
and you were on a blockchain system all
of a sudden you hate blockchain you know
so fear of exposure it creates a
challenge all these different things but
then there's some new technologies like
i/o though we think is a super cool
approach to ledger
um the technology's kind of a whole
different way of doing it we're working
on some stuff even within dealt
acknowledged ease in VMware there's a
project called project conquered like
now we've seen some different emerging
things but I always like to talk about
technology and a sense of not a panacea
you need to look at it more holistically
so so when you talk about trust across
systems blockchain is is certainly a
core element or ledger more broadly
speaking will say electric ledger
technologies but so is a number of other
technologies and so one of the things
that we've been working on at down I
talked a lot about in different content
that I have online and whatnot it's this
notion of you know how do I get to the
intrinsic trust required to achieve
realize who would I call the holy grail
of digital and the holy grail of digital
I would say is is this notion of selling
stuff to strangers in simple terms on
one hand yes it's it's data data is kind
of the obvious answer and selling or
sharing and it's always on your terms
always have to value balanced value with
privacy and IP protection but selling on
your terms data resources compute
storage networking energy rideshares you
anything consumable or services your
domain knowledge turned into an API your
your your skills your behavior your
ethics you know it will turn into an API
on your terms because you want to be
able to go sell your skills to complete
strangers or Angie's List on steroids if
you've heard of Angie's List or your
Yelp or whatever like automated reviews
through interacting with technology that
prevents these my trusted fabrics so to
get to the Holy Grail
we need intrinsic trust across systems
of systems that are inherently
heterogeneous because move the edges is
very is very messy and so so ledger
technologies are part of that if so is
down to the silicon level root of trust
if I have a trusted device and then I
have strong authentication methods with
set device or devices I have open API
ingestion methods so there's
transparency and how I fire that data
this is why I don't deltek we got edge X
founder a project within Linux
Foundation going about two years ago and
open source to do for IOT what Android
did for mobile we think of edge X is its
middleware but it's cute let me create
interoperability between devices and
applications regardless of hardware
software the OS you in general protocol
we're never gonna have one magical
protocol standard for IOT I can deal
with inherent fragmentation and connect
it to any back-end system around an open
API that give Li transparency and how
that interoperability happens so I
combined you know rid of trust and
inauthentic ation methods with OpenID
guys like Ajax and this other stuff
we're doing within the LF edge project
within the crater and all this stuff
these technologies with immutable
storage I need to be able to put data
into object-based storage and and if you
tamper with it the hash values don't
match
combine that with a ledger technology
and some other stuff for untrusted
execution like a whole meal of trust
technologies in transparency elements
this is how I get to that necessarily
trusting transparent transport
transparency it's not one thing it's how
you build systems with the right
technologies if you do this right you
will be able to Freight data in the
physical world send it off into the
ether and collect checks from total
soldiers
this is scale for sure and so how do you
think about of automation that ledger
technology and like digital currencies
right because one of the things that
from an investment thesis that that my
for a long time is every stock bond
currency and commodity eventually gets
digitized and once the assets themselves
are digital now you can unlock the full
potential of automation right but before
you have their little haves kind of
settlement time issues with the assets
let me talk a little bit about that well
yeah I mean it took a great point I mean
it it reminds me of a story I was I was
I mean with a lot of people and I talk
about you know IOT you know a lot of
it's more about the maker movement that
it is about anything it's this ability
to go innovate very quickly you know the
Kickstarter and IndieGoGo zuv the world
you know your raspberry PI's and
argentinos kits and ecosystems and and
then a lot of companies are getting into
you know the old in a better school Emma
you know if I just do what I've always
done faster you all succeed no you have
to start to pivot in and yeah I jump
that I've got a gift card list of people
to send the innovators dilemma book to
it's just a lot of people are kind of
struggling with this and it's
understandable but they really have to
kind of you know change the way you do
things if you want to keep up in this
type market so I was on this call I had
this call around IOT strategy with one
of the big payment provider folks and
and I prepared kind of this for the end
and because I figured would go this way
and I knew that's square you know the
mobile payments solution had really kind
of impacted you know that industry that
the traditional payments you know
processing industry and and we get in
there and we're having this call and
they say oh we don't know what to do you
know quality started we don't want
another square to happen and I'm like oh
I can understand
big impact your business and it was just
kind of spinning and you could tell that
they're just sucking in a barrel I'm
like what do we do your necks what's up
big thing I'd saved this for the very
end I'm like hey guys I need to get I
need to go but have you thought about
when machines start making payments and
it and that kind of blew their mind so
I'm like I didn't say anything about it
except you expect folks like the fact
that this this blew your minds is why
another square is gonna happen to you
because you're not changing how you do
things and and/or think about things and
and so when it comes back to what the
question this notion of automation this
notion of if you can kind of create this
digital currency and you you build the
Trust's and the systems as we're working
on with a bunch of folks I know the IOT
iota folks are working on we're actually
collaborating with them closer here
we're doing some stuff and when its
condition the edge project and I Jax and
there's some new stuff coming that I
can't well talk about yet but if I do it
right real automation and real business
starts to get to really scale when
you're able to kind of trust machines
you know in the sense to you know if I'm
a machine I'm doing there's predictive
maintenance being done and I'm about to
be broken why don't I order the part for
myself and put in a work order and then
have that come we'll have me on the good
fix but better than yeah better than
that how about all the machines in a
region I'll look at themselves and
collaborating say hey look we're all
having issues and so why don't we send
out a tech to a place to you know
upgrade all of these things at once
because we're gonna make that protect
more efficient oh no actually I'm like
about to be broken so I'm gonna order a
new machine because if you fix me you're
just gonna spend your own money over
three years and if you just replace me
you know all of this kind of a smarts
and this automation and these layers of
decision-making and this efficiency
driven at a both at a local regional and
global scale this is the real potential
oh and by the way let me not only talk
about different stakeholders crossing
you in cities and in public and private
boundaries and all that you know a
imagine a world where your your
refrigerator could order food from the
local grocer and make a payment that
grocer then
to a delivery person is a different
party that delivery person comes to your
house and then says hey can I get into
the into the house and then in the house
that the security system owned by
somebody else opens the door so it's not
like one company in the middle of it
whether it's a names honor of Google
like I'm doing great things something
wrong but to be able to do these types
of automation things these these systems
of systems we cannot have any single
enemy on the trucks we need to
collaborate on decentralized trust it's
like you imagine if one company owned
the Internet it just wouldn't work and
so to get to all of these great players
out there working on this notion of hey
let's get out of the lock-in mentality
let's collaborate on enough of kind of
open plumbing both in terms of
interoperability with things like edge X
but then also this distributed trust the
stuff we're doing if I owe that much
other players and whatnot you want some
new stuff coming as I mentioned I need
to get to where I have intrinsic trust
across all domains in the web and mobile
and brick and mortar industrial and home
and auto then we start seeing that
automation stuff really scale and really
cool stuff happen over time for sure and
I guess um can I walk us through you
know one of the examples that you're
most excited about so you take this
distributed ledger technology you
implement it along with these hardware
devices that are collecting data in the
real world and you start getting you
know closer and closer to kind of the
promise of automation what does that
look like or what's one of the examples
that you're super excited about yeah
yeah yeah so many cool things you know I
know talking a lot of bigger stuff and
and you always like to say it's good to
start start small I always say think big
act small and another thing that we're
finding with Dell technologies were
working in so many different industries
manufacturing transportation systems
retail a health care you name it is that
the use case that you start out with
maybe you're just trying to solve a
simple business problem is not it's not
the use case that you end up with
finding the most value in so an example
that pops into my head is this notion of
there's a provider that we're working
with that's working with a steel
manufacturer this
manufacturer uses more power to produce
steel than the city next to them and so
the initial you know question was hey
how do I save some some money on my
electric bill it's it's crazy and so
they come in and they take this holistic
approach looking at all the different
systems you know it in and of course the
core process but also logistics and all
this different stuff and they ended up
not only saving power but they also
saved so much power and got so many
different efficiencies that were able to
sell energy credits back to the power
company and so actually turned it from a
cost center into a profit center in a
sense it's it's really cool when you
start seeing these types of things where
we talk about automation you talk about
the article possible if you set things
up right and kind of architect the apart
police that you can kind of grow as you
get new efficiencies you start focusing
on this trust across networks you know
the sky's the limit I like to say that
if you're if you're focusing on the
utmost that most of this stuff starts
with driving efficiency and the like but
there's only so much you can cut costs
if you're focusing on new money new
revenue pools new opportunity the sky's
the limit so you want to kind of have
that balance and be really thinking
about the big picture for sure and into
as we kind of looked to that future
world of automation which I think you
and I both believe will happen what are
the technical challenges that kind of
stand between us right so from where we
are today to where we're going
challenges that you think need to be
solved yeah so first I will say that one
of the biggest challenges is in biggest
variables and grow also greatest assets
as people within organizations and so
there's a there's that people problem
that we've talked about technically when
you talk about the scale factor first
and foremost it's about then driving
interoperability you know open always
wins in the end the past four years in
kind of IOT has been about everybody
trying to create these platforms and
thinking if I can just lock you in I can
sell your data if you let me and the
reality is is what you need to do is
open it up at the edge where data is
created and this is why we've been
investing in things like
at expand reach other projects and
collaborating with with with players
around Leger technologies and the trust
stuff that you talked about you need to
collaborate on the technical plumbing
that will enable you know open
interoperability between devices and
applications that trust factor that
we've talked about security is a
challenge for sure you know maintaining
privacy and governance but it's also
related back to how you architect to get
to the real potential over time we need
to extend cloud native principles this
notion of platform-independent loosely
coupled architectures micro-services
this notion of continuous delivery those
types of principles that have been you
know taking a good hold and in the cloud
extend those principles to as close to
the edge as possible so I have that
flexibility to rapidly assemble
components from heterogeneous suppliers
around kind of common baseline
frameworks and so edge X was set out to
extend cloud native principles to the
IOT edge as close as you can
where where all of a sudden the devices
become so constrained they can't support
containers and things like that
virtualization I want be able to run
compute across that continuum and
literally move workloads anywhere along
that line and kind of automate that that
analytics and I want to be able to do
that with with providers domain experts
from many different domains around that
open API around that interoperable base
and so the technical challenge is really
kind of come in to architectural how you
do things making sure you abstract that
the data and application from the
underlying infrastructure focus on these
different tools that ensure security and
trust you at scale and and just kind of
build out things in a collaborative
fashion that plumbing you know we need
more consistent funding again imagine if
the internet was owned by one person it
wouldn't work out so well you know you
need that open plumbing to get there so
the technical challenge what people talk
about security security is certainly a
big one it's all about defense
depth many of the breaches that we've
seen in IOT has been whether it's
basically no security applied so we do
need to separate out you know can it be
done versus was it done and it's on you
make a mistake in terms of not not
allowing people to change their password
I mean the briefs that I found the net
in the northeast of the u.s. two years
ago was literally the millions of
cameras got a part of a DDoS attack
because like I think was like under 20
sets of usernames and passwords evidence
all those warmers take a change of
password but be it's really about and
how you apply it and ultimately for
security as a technical what it comes
back to technical challenges is more
about the how do you apply security
technologies in a usable way if you make
things so difficult to use then no one's
going to want to use them or it'll just
bypass it and then bad things happen so
lots of different things were in
architectural considerations and how you
apply the different tools in the right
way and then have you even of course if
you're saying how do you collaborate on
the necessarily open parts to get to the
true potential for sure well listen
Jason I really appreciate you taking the
time to to have this conversation it's
passable to me personally and I can hear
how you're think about it you know
sitting there at the PTO Robel
technology your background not only on
the the kind of mechanics part but then
also the software that's computing etc
so just thanks again from Malva or a
big-time Frankie just educated hey
everyone
pop here if you like this episode of off
the chain and want to help us take
crypto to the top of the Apple Spotify
and other podcast charts please do us a
favor and rate review and subscribe to
review simply go to the off-the-chain
homepage scroll down until you see the
five blank stars taking 15 seconds to
fill those stars in and leave a quick
review goes a long way in helping us
take the entire crypto ecosystem to the
top of the charts
I appreciate you listening and see you
next time on off the chain